not all migrations were
necessarily to Medina. There
were some that were from Mecca
just simply leaving Mecca,
going to Abbasinia, going to
Medina, and elsewhere. We
mentioned that there was a
first initial allowance for a
migration from Mecca to
Abbasinia. Then there was a
second. And this one was more
prominent and it was more more
attended by the many of the
companions
We mentioned that after this,
The prophet made the major
migration which was from Mecca
to Medina. And after this he
called those who were in
Abbasinia, namely Jafar, Ibn
Abia Talib, and those who were
with him there to arrive back
at Medina and to come to Medina
because a new Muslim state had
begun
and during this time, the
prophet sent to the king or
emperor of Ethiopia. He sent a
letter for him, a message
through Omega. Inviting him to
Islam, and responded by
becoming Muslim and mentioning
that had it not been for
certain factors that kept him
from may migrating himself to
Medina, he would have surely
done so. So, is a very good
example of a Mukhabram. We said
Al Mukhabram in the language or
the vocabulary and the
that a Mukhadram in the
terminology of the scholars of
Hadith and historians. This
refers to someone who was a
contemporary of the prophet
Muhammad believed in him but
did not meet him. So he
accepted Islam. He lived in the
same time that the prophet
lived but he did not meet him
physically. And the Jeshi is a
perfect example of this group.
Muhammad and he accepted
Islam. He had some kind of
contact with him in the in the
form of messages that were
relayed between himself and the
prophet via his messengers and
his companions. However, he now
formed him and the prophet
informed us of a Najeshi's
Islam and told the companions
of his death upon Islam. Is the
only time a Najeshi's death is
the only time in which the
prophet made without the body
present. This is the only time
in all of his recorded history
that he made. The funeral
prayer. Without the present.
you know, many of his
companions died or were
murdered, etcetera, elsewhere.
Many of them died in Mecca.
They died in on in route to
battle, returning from battle,
whatever it is, in battle, and
he did not make
which is referred to by the as
the the prayer of the absent.
The absentee funeral prayer
which means that the body is
physically somewhere else and
we make without the body. This
is something that has become
overused, overused. There were
plenty of people that pass way
and the prophet time that were
elsewhere. They there were some
that were in Mecca, there were
some that were all over the the
known world at that time and
they would pass away and the
prophet did not make he only
made it for Najashi. and so
should only be made
in the way that the prophet
made it. Which means that it
should only be made given
circumstances a Najeshi
circumstances. So what the have
done is they've looked at this
he made a she passes away. He
is in Ethiopia. Prophet is in
Medina. He tells his companions
and they stand and they make
they look at this and they see
all the other times when he
informed his companions of
other people's deaths that were
Muslim. But he did not do this.
He did not make so what's the
difference? Right? Why did he
make over in Najashi and not
others of his companions. Is it
an issue of is it an issue of
that an issue of we do not have
access to the body? Is it an
issue of stature? Meaning in
Najesh, he was of high status
and therefore, we make and
others were not of high status.
So, he didn't. This is not the
reason, right? There were
plenty of his companions who
were of higher status than in
Nejeshi and he didn't make
it is when we look at the
circumstances of a Najeshi. So,
the circumstances of a Nejeshi
is that he was in a land where
he was Muslim and his Islam was
discrete. It was not something
that was public. It was not a
public matter, right? Due to
the circumstances that he was
faced with and so, when he
passed away, there was noone to
make over in Najeshi. He was in
a a land of predominantly non
Muslims and he was his Islam
and his identity as a Muslim
was not a matter of public
knowledge. And so when he
passed away there was noone to
make over in Najeshi. So the
prophet made from Madina. The
other companions that passed
away various lands. He made
they made whoever was with them
would have made even if there's
just one person. Even just one
person buries the other and
makes that is enough. That is
sufficient, right? But if
someone dies in a land that's
in in similar to the
circumstances of a Najeshi,
then it is something that is
that should be done and this is
something that is very
that is a very isolated
incident in the time of the
prophet all of the deaths that
had occurred during his
lifetime in 23 years. It was
only something that happened
once. Often times, in many
Masajid in many places, when
someone of of great prominence
passes away such as a scholar
or something of that sort, a
good doer, passes away
many massaged around the world
will make not to say that is
unacceptable in that case. As
we said, it is a difference of
opinion amongst the but we do
know that for a where was done
and performed under these
circumstances. So, the best way
to perform is under these
circumstances as well.
Likewise, The prophet sent
message to Al Na that
married to him
is the daughter of Abu
Sufian Omnibint Abi Sofian, who
later became Muslim. She was
married to
difference of opinion. Many
scholars and many historians
mentioned that obeyed Allah
have been Jash. Was Muslim.
Made the first Hijra. arrived
there in the land of
Christianity in Ethiopia was
impressed by the devoutness
shall we say of the Christians
there and later accepted
Christianity and passed away as
a Christian there. This is what
is mostly reported in the books
of history and Ibn Rahim Allah
mentions this exact same thing.
He mentions that Husband.
husband was he left with her
for the first hijara. He
migrated to Ethiopia. He stayed
there. He later became
Christian. Died upon
Christianity. After his death,
The prophet sent a message to
who at that point had accepted
Islam and would be the one who
is responsible for alright?
Because her father at that
point was not Muslim. And
husband has passed away. And so
her the person who would be her
guardian, her legal guardian in
this instance would be Al Wali.
So it would be a Najayashi. So
the prophet said to him
requesting to be married to
her.
Says
he gave 400 pieces of gold to
her as her dowry on behalf of
the prophet and commissioned
bin Saeed Ibn Al As to Mary.
Umu Habiba to the prophet
The prophet then sent word to
and to a after the seventh year
after Hijalah to have his
companions that are there to
that are residing there that
had made that first and second
Hijla to make Hijra to him in
Medina. And that he should send
them to him. And so and Najashi
commissioned two ships. along
with Amar Ibn to bring them to
the prophet and this was
coinciding with
and by the time that second
group, that group had arrived
from Al Habasha to Medina.
Khaibar had just been, had just
fallen. So, was around that
time. of those who became
Muslim and migrated to the
prophet
along with them was Abu Musal
Ashari. the great Yemeni
scholar and the great narrator
of Hadith, one of the those who
narrated the most narrations of
the prophet that Abu Musa had
migrated from Yemen to Ethiopia
to Abyssinian and from there
migrated with and group of
companions with
migrated to Medina. And finally
met the prophet and was there
with him. And so we surmise
from this that Abu Musal Ash
Hari had arrived and met the
prophet beginning after the
fall of Chaibar. After the fall
of Haibar. Which is important
in the science of Fiq. Ibn
he
says
A
[Silence]
and the prophet initially sent
them to Ethiopia. There were
other places they could have
gone. But the politics of the
area and the social climate was
very unpredictable. I have to
remember that these tribes
especially the tribes of Mecca
And the tri of Quraish. They
were at the heart
the destination of all of the
Arab tribes and the entirety of
the area. Everyone made this
migration to Mecca every year.
Some of them performed Hajj,
some of them came just to
capitalize on the commerce at
the time. And so, everyone
would come to Mecca and then
everyone would leave. And it
was always this. So,
people made it a priority to
have good relations with
Qureish. Because they were in
charge of Mecca. And if Quraish
wanted, they could make things
very hard for other people. And
they could make things very
hard for other tribes. And
there were certain tribes in
certain regions that this
yearly migration yearly hedge
that took place was their
livelihood. Meaning they would
make in commerce, in sales,
they would make their
sustenance for the rest of the
year. So it was really a or
death situation and so, one of
the things that you did not
want to do if you were from
Yemen or if you were from
Southern Arabia or if you were
from Hashem or if you were from
any of these areas, one thing
you don't want to do is have
bad relations with because if
they decide to exile you, to
excommunicate you, if they
decide that you're not allowed
to attend this or other tribes
to put to put to leverage other
tribes against you. Things
could become very bad And so
while other tribes in the Arab
region and in the Arab
Peninsula may have been neutral
at that time. It's unsure and
unclear what the future holds.
They their neutrality could be
swayed. One or another based on
how things turn out and so,
what is the point of leaving
Mecca, migrating to somewhere
that is just in a year or two
going to turn against you. Now,
not only are you being turned
against but you're being turned
against by people that you have
no relationship with, that you
are, an interloper amongst and
so, in that case, it would just
be safer to remain in Mecca
amongst your own tribesmen. So,
to send them far away from
these politics, he sent them to
a Nejeshi, which is the
closest, the closest,
empire or closest refuge that
they could go to be more or
less insulated from this from
these politics and this
political climate that was very
unpredictable at the time. And
Najesh, he was Christian but he
was known for his fairness. He
was known to be very just, very
fair, and very reasonable man.
And so the prophet sent them
there to him under the pretext
that he is a Christian, but
that he is fair and he is a
person who's very god fearing
and so when they made that
migration there, again, Quraish
did try to leverage in the
against them which is what the
prophet predicted was going to
happen. And so, they sent a
delegation headed by Abdullah.
And later accepted Islam But
was known Who hearers,
constituents, he was known to
his peers as being a man very
very well spoken. He was
somebody that was extremely
clever and was one of those
folks that could kind of talk
his way out of anything, right?
And so, they sent him along
with Abdullah, Quraish sent him
to a to get to get in his ear
and to convince him to turn
over these companions that had
migrated to him to turn on his
own refugees. and so, they
arrived there in Ethiopia and
they used all of their, all of
their ties and connections to
try to do this. they tried to
leverage Najeshi's own courtesy
against him. His own courtiers
tried to leverage them against
him. Meaning that people that
are close to a Najeshi you
know, they would try to get
them to put in a good word for
them and to try to convince in
the Jeshe to turn them over And
also some of Najeshi's generals
to turn on him or to convince a
Najeshi to hand them over. And
regardless who approached and
Najeshi with this this
proposition of handing over his
refugees, he refused to do so
and so, Abdullah decided to
play on a own faith. He's a
Christian man And they knew
that Christians were devout
They have very devout reverence
for Jesus. and so, they decided
to kind of instigate a Najeshi
against them and they said, you
know, I mean, these guys that
you've taken in, these
refugees, they don't hold Asaph
and Mariam. They don't hold
Jesus in the regard that you
do. They say that he's a slave,
right? They left out the part
that a slave to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala, right? They just
said a slave and it comes off
the way that you say that. It
comes off as if they're saying
that he is less less less of a
man, let alone be a prophet.
And so, they brought many
presents and gifts and tried to
butter up in Najeshi and so,
upon hearing this, he requested
that the refugees be brought
and at the head of them, and he
asked them, what it is they
really say and what's their
belief with regards to E7
Mariam. And so, when they
arrived, Abdul Kaim tells us
here that when they arrived,
Jafar said to the gatekeepers,
of a Najeshe's court,
that tell your king that the
that the allegiance or the
alliance of Allah is here
requesting to enter And so and
Najeshi said to them have them
repeat themselves. That's quite
a claim. And so they said again
reiterated that the alliance of
Allah of God himself is here.
And so they came in and
was speaking on their behalf
and he asked what is your
belief and your prophet's
belief with regards to Isa Ibn
Mariam. And so Jafar, recited
the first the first, third, of
Surat Mariam. Of Surat Mariam,
which is dedicated to the story
of Asa Alaihi Sal largely and
the story of Zacharia and Yahia
and Mariam. And so and Najash
he listened very carefully.
After which he picked up a a
small twig from the ground and
said there is Asa Alaihi Salam
is not more by even this much
than you have described him.
Right? So clearly here we see
that in Najesh he was not
deluded into thinking what's
modern Christianity usually
preaches and that is that is
god or that his one of three or
any of these things that many
Christians at that time we
could dare say the majority of
Christianity believed something
very similar to what Muslims
believe with regards to Isa
Alaihi Salam. And so
commanded that's all of the
presence that was sent were
sent by Quresh be returned to
them. And when you
this is how it works. If a
person is in a position of
power or authority, a position
of discretion and someone
brings them a gift, right? I'm
in a position of authority, a
position of discretion, and
someone brings me a gift,
person that I don't know. I
don't know this person. They
bring me a gift. Why did they
bring me this gift? obviously
because they want something.
There is no such thing as a
free lunch. People give things
to receive better. That's how
human beings work, right? And
so, For this reason, the
prophet prohibited the
companions who collect
and the companions who collect
and so forth and go to
calculate for people. He
prohibited them from accepting
gifts. Right? Because the only
reason they're receiving this
gift from this stranger is
because of their position. And
if you accept the gift in that
position, you are indebted to
the person that has given you
this gift, with something in
return. That's how it works.
It's a transaction. It's
something that's usually not
spoken about A person doesn't
bring a gift and say, here I
give you this but I want
something in return. It's
understood and so, at Najesh,
he returned these gifts because
they gave him these gifts under
the pretext that he would hand
over his refugees. and he
refused this and refused their
gifts. And
and the disillusion of his
priest. It was a Christian
country to the disillusion of
his priest and Najashi was
unwilling to believe that Asah
Alaihi Salam was any different
than the Quran's description of
him. And
And
Najeshi at that point
promised his refugees. And his
band of companions, he promised
them He promised them stability
in his land and refuge. And he
promised them safety. And he
informed them that anyone who
insults you or attempts to harm
you here in my dominion and my
kingdom will be punished for
doing so.
are considered to be almost
their honored guests. He
promised them safety. and he
mentioned that no matter what
Quresh gives him, even if it
were a mountain of gold, he
will not turn them over to
Quresh and so, Quresh now were
outplayed, right? The prophet
predicted the leverage, and the
political reach that Quraish
and those tribes had on the
Arab Peninsula and so he sent
his companions somewhere where
their authority would be
questioned. And to a place that
was economically, independent
and autonomous, not reliant on
Quraish, and not reliant on the
religion of idolatry, and not
reliant on the migration and
the Hajj that happened every
year. This is very important
Very important because if he
sent these companions to seek
refuge in another tribe or in
another place where they shared
the same religion as Quraish or
they shared an economy with
Quraish or they shared some
kind of incentive with Quraish,
they would have probably been
slain. However Alhamdulillah.
The prophet thought forward and
outplayed them in this and
outsmarted them. He says
Quresh and
[Silence]
uncle Islam and many other
prominent members of Quraish
society And so Quraish started
to get very worried that a lot
of political clout is now
making its way over to the
prophet side. At first, it was
just, you know,
interlopers that were passing
through Mecca or slaves or
servants or people that were
poor or not from any reputable
tribe. But now we have people
Hamza, Ibn Abdul Mukbalib
and you have these prominent
members and the elite of Quresh
society and tribesmen start to
become Muslim. This is a
problem. Because that means
that political plot and
influence is now transitioning
to the Muslim side. This is
when they started to get really
really worried And so They
decided to band together and to
collectively banish Hashem and
Beni Al Mut Talib. Benny Hashem
and Benim Mukpalib, the prophet
strive. They decided that all
of the tribes of Quresh were
going to get together You know,
his one uncle is now become
Muslim, Hamza. And his uncle
Abu Talib is not Muslim but
he's protecting him and he's
acting he's Muslim. So, we
have to take matters a little
bit more seriously and so, they
decided to get together, the
main tribes and to banish an
excommunicate as it were, Benny
Hasham and Benny Abdul and
Beniel Muktalib. But they
decided not to marry anyone
from those tribes and that
noone from those tribes was to
marry outside of their own
tribe. Nor will they speak to
them. It is it is against this
bond, this allegiance to even
interact with them, to totally
ostracize them. Nor to they are
not to speak to them, they are
not to wed from them, they are
not to deal with them, They are
not to sell or buy, or trade,
or anything. Total
excommunication, until they
decide to give up the messenger
of
because they wanted to kill
him. The only thing that
stopped them really from
killing him by Allah's grace is
his status as being from
Benihashem. And so this was
very prominent tribe in
Quraish. It's the most
prominent tribe of Quraish. So
they were really unable to
unable to do really what they
wanted to do. They're unable to
do that because of the fallout
that would happen. The fallout
would be inevitably war and so
forth. And so they decided,
look, we're going to
excommunicate, completely
ostracize, and to have a an
economic embargo against Benny
Hasham until they hand over the
prophet and so they wrote this
in a document and they had the
main tribesmen, tribe leaders
signed this and they went and
hung it in the Kaaba itself.
This document, right?
Basically, them all agreeing to
oppress the messenger of Allah
and anyone who would associate
with him. And they took this
and they hung it in the Kaaba
almost as if to make themselves
feel a little bit better about
what they're really doing.
[Silence]
Ibn And